الاوضاع في الاقتصاد العالمي روسيا والصين
البلدان الوحيدان اللذان اوضح انهم لن
يوقع على هذا النص في العمل الماضي كما
عشره في مجموعه العشرين اكدوا انه من
الضروري ان امتثل القانون الدولي في نظام
التعدد
الجهات وهذا كافه المبادئ الموضحه في
ميثاق الامم المتحده والالتزام بالقانون
اللساني الدولي
كل عضو في مجموعه العشرين وكل دوله على
الاطلاق تستمر بتحمل تكلفه حرب روسيا
العدائيه هذه الحرب التي يمكنني ان يها
رئيس بوتين غدا اذا ما اختار ذلك
الولايات المتحده لم ترغب بهذه الحرب
عملنا جاهدين للحيله دونها
التحديات الاساسيه التي تؤثر على حياه
شعوبنا فحتى بينما نقف الى جانب اوكرانيا
تدافع عن نفسها حنحل ايهما في هذا العمل
نحن عازمنا على مع دول اخرى لتقديم الحلول
لمواجهه هذه التحديات المشتركه وهذا ما
فعلناه اليوم في مجموعه العشرين هذه
التحديات تشمل ازمه الغذاء غير المسبوقه
في العالم على امران في نفس الوقت ونوصل
الغذاء الى
مساعده دول على
تطوير مرونتها وقدرتها الغذائيه المتحده
تقود على الصعيدين لتمويل اكثر من نصف
برنامج الغذاء العالمي
في العمل الماضي فقط والتزمنا باحدى عشر
مليار دولار اضافي على مدى خمسه عوامل
القادم لتعزيز مرونه الدول وقدرتها
الغذائيه الدول الافريقيه بالتحديد
اخبرتنا مرارا ان اكثر
هو المساعده البنايه القدرات المستدامه
لاطعام شعوبهم ونحن نتعاون من اجل تحقيق
ذلك الان
والمستويات غير المسبوقه من اعدام الامن
الغذائي المدفوعه بتغير المناخي وجائحه
كوفيد 19 والنزاعات على ان الازمه فاقمت
بشكل متعمد من قبل رئيس بوتين الذي قام
بتسليح مجاعه العالم او شعوب حول العالم
والفضل جهودي
وتركيا
السمحات 22 مليون طن من الغذاء يساوي
مليارات رغيفه خبز لمغادره الموانع
الاوكرانيه الى العالم اليوم
وروسيا مره اخرى تباطئ وتصدير الغذائي من
اوكرانيا ومبادره البحر الاسود سوف تنفذ
18 من مارس فاروسيا رفضت الالتزام
بتجديدها الرساله التي بعثناها اليوم
واضحه وسع اتفاق مبادره البحر الاسود ومن
دون اي تاجيل كما ناقشنا السبلة لمكافحتهم
في الولايات المتحده لوحدها
اكثر من 70 الف شخصا خلال العام الماضي
وهو المتسبب الرئيسي لقتل الاشخاص من
اعمار 18 الى 40 عاما لا دوله بامكانها
مكافحه هذه مشكل لوحدها علقت العسل
غير القانونيه
وتفكيك يا جماعه
الاجراميه العالميه كل هذه تحديات تتطلب
جهودا دوليه منسقه ولهذا السبب من المهم
وللمره الاولى فان وزراء مجموعه العشرين
الطالب وبتعاون دولي قوي لمكافحه المخدرات
غير القانونيه وكما عبر الوزراء اليوم
فعلينا ابتكر جهودا مركزا لجمع الحكوماتي
والمنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه والقطاع
الخاص وغيرهم لمعالجه هذه المشكله
هذه مساله
قانون وامنيه ولكن بشكل
عامه وازمه عالميه بشكل متزايد اليوم ايضا
ناقشنا تحديات اخرى حيث يتوقعوا الشعوب
العالم ان العمل عليها معا مثل ما اجت
ازمه المناخ ومساعده مجتمعاتنا
مع التغييرات وتعزيز الصحه العالميه لكي
نكون مستعدين لمنع ومعالجه الازمات
القادمه وش الفرصه نتحدث على اهم شيء
اجتماعات اليوم نيجيريا جنوب افريقيا
والبرازيل واندونيسيا وهولندا والمكسيكي
والارجنتين وبالتاكيد الهند
واسمحوا لي ان احيي اولا رئاسه الهند
وزير الخارجيه
على مجموعه واسعه اتفاق التي عكسناها في
وثيقتنا واخلاصتنا وهذه الاولى لوزاره
مجموعه العشرين الوزير انا اتحدث كثيرا
ودائما اتابع كلامنا ونعمل وعلى تمديد
الاستراتيجيه باشكال جاده وقويه ودعمين
اجنده الطموحه لمجموعه العشرين وتطوير
مبادره الملك والهند على التكنولوجيا على
الضروريه والتي اطلقها الرئيس بعدين في
بعض العام الماضي
والتزامنا بحقوق الانسان والقيام
الديمقراطيه يوم غد
وانا سنضم الى ضرائنا اليابان واستراليا
في المجموعه الرباعيه لحين ما ياتي لحركه
البضاعه الحره عبر بحارنا وكذلك تعزيز
تعاون نحاول المساعدات الانسانيه واغاثه
الكوارث هذه الاهميه طرحت مره اخرى
بعد الهزات الارضيه في تركيا وسوريا
التفاعلنا مع المجموعه الرباعيه
مجرد امثله قليله عن
توثيق الولايات المتحده ليتحالفات لتعزيز
قدراتنا على الايفاء ليعودنا لشعوبنا هذه
الرحله في وسطها
الى اجتماع الوزاري لمجموعه الخمس زائد
واحد كل ما زادت هذه الشركات
وقلنا بتقويتها وتعزيزاها كلما تمكنا من
معالج التحديات العابر الحدود تؤثر على
شعوبنا وتوسيع قدراتنا الامريكيين وتعزيز
امنه وتحقيق مصالحنا وما نجهده في نيودله
واستغنى وغيرها هي ان الدول ترغب بالتشارك
مع الولايات المتحده لانها ترانا دائما
موجوده للمشاركه بحلم الشاكل ورعايه
والوقوف للدفاع عن القوانين
وكل دوله اختيار مسارها بعيدا عن العنف
والاعمال القسريه والتهديد
مجموعه العشرين اليوم
وقمت بحذفهم على عكس قرارهم غير المسؤول
والعوده لتطبيقي اتفاقيه والتي تضعها
الحدود على ترساويه الولايات المتحده
والروسيه الاتحاديه
الامثال على المشتركه ثم لدينا وكذلك ما
تتوقعوا شعوب العالمي منك قوى نوويه
الوزير الخارجيه بانه مهما حصل في العالم
وفي حول علاقاتنا الولايات المتحده دائما
تكون مستعد للانخراط والعمل على ضبط
الاسلحه كما كما فعلت الولايات المتحده في
ذروه الحرب بارده كما تحدثت عن اعتقال كما
طرحت المساله في عده مناسبات الولايات
المتحده طرحت مقترحا جدا ماسكو عليها ان
تقبله نحن عازمنا لعاده وكل مواطن امريكي
اخر اعتقل بشكل
غير عادل الى وطنه
المشاهدين نكتفي بهذا القدر من المؤتمر
الصحفي لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي